he is the man of somebody's hour on
thursday night the question is is when
will he go off the board and then what
happens next one of the top
prospects in the 2021
nfl draft from north dakota state
university the bison himself
trey lance how are you trey lance
i'm doing great i can't complain how are
you i am doing fine
so you know because usually at this
point in time somebody who's uh the
subject of national draft speculation is
ready for this thing to be over
are you one are you are you in that boat
right now trey
uh i'm definitely excited for thursday
i'll say that um
it's been a long process but it's been
awesome you know people say it's a weird
year but i guess you know
me and this draft class we don't know
any different um but it's been a ton of
fun and i'm definitely looking forward
to
you know hearing my name called and find
out where i'm going to be at well i i've
been doing the draft for
for uh for a bit trey and one of my
favorite aspects about it is the journey
and how journeys are are are crowned in
a way
with opportunity knocking and that's the
road in front
i love those stories how did you get to
north dakota state
trey lance yeah my recruiting process
was a little different you know i'm from
smaller town in southwest minnesota um
yeah you know offered by some schools in
sps some schools in the mac
uh most of the ivy league schools uh and
then you know
i guess probably early in my junior year
i got switched you know kind of on the
recruiting boards or whatever you want
to call it um from quarterback to
athlete and that's when that whole kind
of
idea started that i wasn't a quarterback
at that point i had already been
recruited by north dakota state as a
quarterback
um fell in love with it you know the the
the conversations about me playing a
different position were kind of fast i
wasn't really interested
i knew i was at the quarterback
believing in myself and north dakota
state obviously
i wanted to have this opportunity to be
where i'm at right now and north dakota
state you know if i wasn't being offered
by alabama oklahoma
clemson or ohio state you know north
dakota state was the best option for me
without a doubt
um also just as far as you know fbs
being you know
bigger and better um i don't think
that's always the case uh and for me
getting to north dakota state and seeing
you know the expectation of to go to
state
is winning every single game and winning
national championships
um i didn't want to go to school and
hope to play for a bowl game
well i mean you know i i don't normally
like to ask uh
somebody who's getting ready to be
drafted and about
their recruiting process and asking
about um to read their i guess
scouting sheet in a way but i'm
unfamiliar
with why somebody would consider you not
a quarterback prospect as you're getting
ready to
to go um into college football what what
were the
were you why why were you not considered
a quarterback prospect
trey yeah it was um
really similar actually kind of to the
the feedback i hear now or as far as
negative
um just you know didn't throw the ball
enough didn't play enough games
um you know we ran we were fairly run
heavy offense obviously really similar
to what i did at mexico state you know
probably threw the ball 20 times a game
um and it wasn't anything past that very
consistently
um went to a small school didn't play
very much competition
uh so that's kind of a really similar
like you know like as you know
to what i hear right now but again it's
just those things that i can't control
you're still hearing that right now
literally because
um uh you know you're you're potentially
on the verge of being a top five
quarterback drafted player in the
national football league
and i i'm wondering because there's so
much talk about
shoulder chips and chips on shoulders
these days
do you have one because of all this trey
uh yeah i mean i i like proving people
wrong
you know that's what i love to do i
think just my being from a small town
being
you know kind of the middle of nowhere
uh it's what i've done my whole life and
it's kind of i guess what i love to do
uh but excited like i said for this
opportunity and to be able to
have people you know organization that
believes in me and wants me to be a part
of what they do in their operation
uh but yeah you know i'm always you know
there's always gonna be critics and
stuff like that i don't pay attention to
it a whole lot
trey lance courtesy of sleep number here
just a couple days before the nfl draft
in cleveland ohio right here on the rich
eisen show in terms of
organizations interested in you joining
their uh their
their programs um how are your zooms
with the 49ers trey
how are they um
actually um they've been going well i
haven't had a
any more with them than i have with any
other team um but yeah definitely
looking forward to it like i said
finding out where i'm gonna be um
man i wish i knew just as much as you
did probably more
uh but i really don't know where i'm
gonna end up at so hopefully you know
thursday we'll find out
so uh how many of the zooms or
conversations of the 49ers have taken
place since they moved up to
number three overall trey which is about
i'll give you the time frame about
four weeks ago last month how much
have you had with san francisco there um
just just a couple phone calls uh really
has been the most
um haven't had i don't even know if i've
had a zoom within the last four weeks
honestly
uh maybe one zoom with something but
other than that it's just been a phone
call
uh and it's you know not like it's an
everyday thing or anything like that
just you know their their regular
housekeeping making sure they got my
contact info things like that
so did you are you in shanahan's phone
have we confirmed that then trey have
you got no
no it's not uh that's not not not not
code samhain no
okay well look i i'm i'm i'm uh
i'm hearing that you're you're picking
the brains of uh
everybody you possibly can um earlier on
in the show
my colleague who i'll be sitting on the
draft set with daniel jeremiah
shared a story that you reached out to
him wanting to have breakfast and the
two of you
chit-chatted about the draft is that a
is that a true story trey
that is a true story i got connected to
him um
and and obviously as you know he's one
of those people
as you are that knows a lot about the
league how it works uh so for me it was
about you know not only getting feedback
on myself but
but just the insight that he has as far
as how the league works how to operate
um and him being around that those
situations for so long
um i'm just another person that like i
said like you said uh knows a lot about
it and for me it's about learning as
much as i possibly can at this point
so for what i i love it so why who else
have you reached out to like that from i
guess the talent evaluation community
because you know it definitely um how
else have you done that with trey
a ton of guys um that are playing right
now uh so just being able to be around
guys you know i
i got to be with obviously carson a lot
got the symphony time around deshawn
josh dobbs
goff gardner minshew you know the list
goes on like sam darnold kyle and
sam darnold uh and josh allen excuse me
um
having the opportunity to just bounce
ideas off those guys and learn you know
how they operate what they do in the
offseason and just you know
learn like truly just immerse myself in
what they do and what they've been about
um and obviously those guys having
having success in the league
um is something i want to do so for me
it's about you know learning as much as
i can and until i'm competing against
those guys are you cold calling them or
you're basically like hey get you you
got their number and
like hey hey uh josh you know it's trey
and and uh i got connected to him uh uh
thankfully i haven't just uh you know
called them out of the blue and then
like
you know hey my name's trey
i i thankfully i i've gotten connected
to them through some other people
whether it's
trainers or quarterback coaches or
whatever it is um
you know that thankfully you know
they're willing to answer my questions
and get to hang out with me
and things like that um so very thankful
for them but no i'm not just just
finding their number in the in the
archives and diamonds
so um in a few minutes i have left with
you trey lance what
why the second pro day can you walk me
through the genesis
of of trey lance pro day 2.0
yeah i just wanted to give teams an
opportunity to see me again
uh i want teams to know whether zoom
meetings are throwing on the field i
want them to know exactly what they're
getting
um you know just want to be as real as
possible
um for me it was like i said you know i
didn't obviously played one game
in 2020 um so people didn't get to see
me you know
a large sample size of me and i
understand you know only playing 17
games and things like that
but i wanted to give people you know
another chance to see me throw and do
whatever they wanted to see me do
uh you know first and foremost before
before
thursday so what what would a team be
getting
if they draft trey lance trey lance what
a team beginning uh
a com a competitor first and foremost uh
someone that obviously loves the game
loves football and and wants to have the
opportunity to play
i believe in myself i'm confident um in
what i can do
but at the same time i understand that
i'm going to come in and learn as much
as i possibly can
whatever my role is that first year or
week one i'm gonna do to the best of my
ability
and at the end of the day i'm like i say
come in earn respects from as many
people as i possibly can everyone in the
locker room and
in the organization um and just handle
myself the right way how was your zoom
with bill belichick how'd that one go
i actually uh did not say that i had to
zoom in
yes you are a veteran trey this is
well done very well done
very well done but you read you read the
blitz you saw me coming off the edge
and you you you you looked me off i
didn't take the bait
and tried to get it but it was good
right it was good
i actually definitely did not did not
ever say that
[Laughter]
the excitement level that so many fan
bases have
for you to be drafted from the 49ers
atlanta
um you know uh new england
denver potentially carolina um
have you let's just put it this way have
you had zooms with
have you had conversations with all of
them how many teams have you had
conversations with
trey um now i've had conversations with
probably i would think around 20 25
teams
um on zoom and it's been over you know
obviously over
since since march or since february um
so it's been awesome like i said to get
as many in front of as many people as i
possibly can
and you know the way the league works is
you never know what's gonna happen you
know the next year or a few years down
the road
uh so for me just you know being a
genuine and real as possible and again
letting people know exactly what they're
going to get
well you being so tireless wait for it
trey lance uh
good thing you've partnered up with the
sleep and wellness partner of the
national football league and sleep
number
do you like that turn right there trey
you like that one
our solid thank you sir solid yeah sleep
numbers
is absolutely amazing uh i mean they're
a perfect partner for me just because i
value my sleep in recovery
uh and i can tell the difference in my
body when i'm not getting the sleep and
recovery that i need
uh so everything they've done for me and
and the sleep number 360 smart bed uh
has been a huge competitive advantage
for me over the last few months like
just being able to get my recovery and
and check my app in the morning my sleep
number iq up and check what my iq score
was every morning and make sure that i'm
i'm staying up up on my recovery and
getting as much sleep and rest as i need
to has been
huge and it can continue to be a
competitive advantage for me in the
future did they hook you up with dak
i heard they hooked you up with jack
sleep number they did they surprised me
on a zoom call uh the other day and i
was that was really cool not only
obviously being a part of the sleep
number family with him uh but you get to
talk to him you know as a football
player as a person
uh and getting to know him a little bit
uh being able to get connected
i'm excited to obviously compete and
learn as much as i possibly can from him
uh i've heard a lot about him and the
way he operates and obviously see it in
the media but being able to talk to him
was a really cool experience for sure
and what was bill belichick's sleep iq
score trey did you get that from him in
the zone
i actually never said that i
[Laughter]
say that again what'd you say i said i
said you're getting closer just
just keep shooting keep shooting okay
very good you know what his sleep number
score
is we just want you in new england
that's right that's all i'm trying to
say
we just want you that's my patreon
for love it's a true story well done
chris i was
i've been digging for you no i'm just
coming through the front door
it's a beautiful place to play football
certainly uh
in january and february trey uh i've
heard nothing but great things
about you it's a pleasure to meet you
through this conversation
and i hope i have many of them uh with
you at the next level
uh i i good luck in uh on thursday night
and beyond i appreciate the time
absolutely thank you so much really
enjoyed it thank you right back at you
that's trey lance
the 2019 walter payton award winner
north dakota state university bison
prospect right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here